yesterday President Trump made a
surprise visit to the al Asad Air Base
in Iraq where he visited the brave men
and women serving abroad during
Christmas meanwhile back at home the
mainstream media trashed the present
over his visit with our troops watch
this
in retrospect and I give him credit for
going to Iraq but his actual performance
there was was shameful the president
seems to have confused in some way this
troop to point this troop visit with the
campaign rallies was really a political
rally in front of troops in Iraq he
treats the troops like prompts it
converts the troops into a partisan
plaything is the United States Congress
and the people of the United States who
are supporting our armed forces they
don't belong to him he's like the Grinch
instead of I'm being honest no it's all
crazy mess it was so negative and so you
want it you want positivity when it
comes to Christmas it is perplexing why
would he visit the troops and do that
the all too predictable attacks
continued on CNN where pundits actually
criticized Trump for autographs take a
look the pool reporters traveling said
that the troops brought the hats with
them including one hat that said Trump
2020 we will have to see if that
actually proves to be the case the
question is if they if they brought them
or if the president brought them what
commander allowed that to really happen
because this is very much against
military policy and regulation troops
are not supposed to be involved in
political activities the US military is
not a political force and there's no
question the same Trump 2020 and make
America great again
those are political slogans of a Trump
campaign they are not governmental
sayings to put to say the least
of course you didn't hear those attacks
under Obama in 2008 when he was running
for president then candidate Obama
signed memorabilia and rallied the
troops during an event at a military
base in Kuwait four years later as
president running for re-election Obama
also signed autographs it took pictures
at a base in Afghanistan of course he
did but now that it's Trump and he's the
president
this is no longer allowed prime example
of blatant media bias in hypocrisy
joining us now is Fox News national
security strategist Sebastian Gorka
national security analyst Morgan
Ortega's and RNC national spokesman
Kaylee mackaninee thank you so much for
being here Kaylee I want to start with
you I mean the hypocrisy and the double
standard is so blatant here but do the
American people that they see through
this what should they read from these
these media reports Oh Jason there's no
doubts that the American people see
through this here is the beauty of all
of this if there is any silver lining
it's this that the media has eliminated
the need of the President to call them
out to expose their bias they have
become so biased so ridiculous so
outrageous literally writing a headline
while President Trump is in there to
visit the troops that he is becoming the
first president since 2002 to not visit
the troops that is fake news that's at
its finest they have become a parody of
themselves and doing so they are
exposing themselves the American people
are very much in tune with this and
they're doing themselves a disservice by
going so negative because it's so
blatant and so obvious to even the
casual observer Sebastian you're very
close to the president he served in the
White House why do you think the
president actually made this trip it
wasn't to sign autographs on make
America great again hats I know why he
made it Jason I called the White House I
spoke with the White House on Christmas
Eve he did this because this was
important to him and it was important
for Melania I believe this is the first
time a first lady has visited an active
war zone since 1969 and the fact that
CNN and the rest of the fake news
industrial complex is attacking those
that wear the uniform of the Republic
that are serving in a war zone
it's an utter disgrace and an outrage I
worked for the Defense Department for
more than five years I was subject to
the rules that require you to remain
politically neutral as a civilian and
I've read the regulations that apply
to those in uniform you are not allowed
to be involved in political campaigning
Jason you know that as well as I do the
idea that you are asking your
commander-in-chief for his autograph on
a hat is not a political campaign action
all we need to know right now is if you
love this country like the president
does if you love this country like our
servicemen and women then CNN and the
rest of that crew will hate you it is
really that simple yeah III thought that
the reporting was absolutely really was
shameful but joining me here in New York
in studios morgan ortega thank you so
much for being here most people don't
know this but you served our country in
both Saudi Arabia and Iraq I think there
was a years of service out of your life
serving our country and we thank you for
that service the president comes over
it's an unannounced trip the people
there they don't know that the
president's coming they may have gotten
a couple hours notice if that and when
you serve overseas right you take what's
precious and dear to you what you care
about in your space is very limited so
the fact that these people had this on
hand knowing maybe with an hour's noted
that the president's coming says
something about the intention of worth
these people believe and he got a
rousing rousing applause when he walked
into that room did he and you know
what's interesting when Barack Obama
when George W Bush when other presidents
regardless of party go to the region
where the troops are in they're serving
they get rousing applause and why is
that because these members of the
service serve at the pleasure of the
commander-in-chief they're away from
their family they're away from their
friends on Christmas and it's energizing
to see your president there they're
excited to see him you know in a trip
like that when I was at the US Embassy
and Riyadh for example if we had a
cabinet official or a high-level
official coming in that would have been
planned weeks in advance so they were to
the criticism that this had something to
do with Syria or the shutdown it's
almost impossible to plan something like
that it would have been done it that at
the highest levels many weeks in advance
and so I think that this is this is one
of those things often there's times
where we look at something that the
President did and you know you see a lot
of hullabaloo from the media sometimes I
think it's being overblown this is one
of those cases
whereas you know you know I'm in the
reserves and I do not speak on behalf of
the military in fact I serve with people
who are Democrats who are Republicans
who are down the middle and we don't
bring our partisan affiliation into the
uniform but when the president is there
regardless of party you're happy to see
your president and to see these
reporters I gotta say how all this
happened is there is a reporter who
zoomed in and took pictures of people's
faces and their name plates which by the
way is not the best OPSEC to begin with
and took make sure that they were
documented on Twitter with these maggots
and with the Trump banners for the
explicit purpose of calling them out and
that reporter I mean I wouldn't let that
person back on the White House press
corps if it were me yeah Caylee is there
anything that the president can do that
would be right because it doesn't seem
to matter what this president does they
always seem to find fault in it even
visiting the troops at Christmastime
that's exactly right he does what is
right and yet is still called out for it
with blatant bias with editorializing
with fake news stories you know I
watched the entirety of his 25-minute
speech it was a very beautiful speech
for those who didn't see it aired life
go watch that he literally sits there
and thanks the troops and he says thank
you for winning back 20,000 square miles
of territory for from Isis thank you for
liberating three million citizens their
extraordinary accomplishments thank you
for sacrificing and being away from your
families he said and did everything
right but that's just it he can do
everything right the media however as
found by a Harvard study is 90% negative
they will remain negative but at the end
of the day we have an election in 2020
the American people will reward him for
doing what is right despite the media
onslaught despite the liberal and the
leftist onslaught that hinders every
single day and I also thought that
bringing in the first lady and having
the first lady make that trip and
visiting with the troops oh it's also a
very nice touch absolutely but Sebastian
you again with the troops the message
that it stands not only to the people
there in Iraq that are serving but
overseas in Japan and all across the
world the message has got to be a
resounding Donald Trump has your back
you took the words right out of my mouth
that's the next thing I was going to say
so
I'd like to encourage all the viewers to
go back to my Twitter to feed at said
Gawker look at Sarah Huckabee Saunders
look at the photographs from in Iraq
look at the faces of those servicemen
and women look at the photographs from
Ramstein from Germany they are so
overjoyed that on Christmas Day Donald
Trump and Melania Trump don't spend
their precious time together in the
White House or in mar-a-lago
they fly to the Middle East they fly to
that base they meet with these people
they shake their hands they take their
selfies they know that one trip tells
them everything they need to know about
how much this commander-in-chief has
their back and most really really
Sebastian I I've got just a few seconds
I want to give ya Morgan the last word
here you know the only thing that I've
seen Barack Obama did the only thing he
was willing to cut was the defense
budget but this president has plussed
that up by tens of billions of dollars
and what's also not being talked about
is on that trip the president was
meeting with his senior military
commanders on the ground and he's
already the team has already started to
show that they're thinking about perhaps
a new strategy for Syria as it relates
to keeping troops there the president
has indicated that he's going to keep
troops in or out for people like me who
are a defense Hawks this was a fantastic
trip because the president got to see
firsthand all of this stuff that is
deliberated in the National Security
Council he got to see it firsthand I
think it might have even you know not
necessarily changed his mind but helped
him sort of strengthen his strategy as
it relates to Syria and Iraq and that's
incredibly important no one's talking
about that because they just want to
criticize for signing a hat III hope the
president continues to do this it means
the world and their families back home
and do it during Christmastime and shame
on the media for reporting it as they
did they did not give you the full
picture of what was happening and thank
you and God bless the troops who are
serving in their families we appreciate
you joining us tonight